So there's been a lot of discussion of if
and when Joe Biden is going to denounce violence
that is taking place in different places around
the country.
And the Trumpet's and Donald Trump himself
have focused in a lot on this.
Why won't Joe Biden denounce this?
Why won't Joe Biden denounce that?
Now, before we get to the sort of substance
here, which is that Joe Biden did it and a
lot of people on the left are furious with
him and the right is just simply ignoring
it.
Does Joe Biden really need to denounce anything
in the sense that we currently have violence
happening under the leadership of Donald Trump
and even though Donald Trump is trying to
insist that violence is what's in store in
Biden's America?
Do you look back at when Biden was vice president,
things were relatively calm.
And the violence that we are seeing now to
the extent that it exists is a lot of it is
being done by Trump supporters.
Of course, not all of it, but it is all happening
as Donald Trump is president of the United
States.
But OK, let's put that we'll table that argument
for now.
And let's just say people want Biden to denounce
the violence.
Well, he did it.
Joe Biden did it in a speech in Pennsylvania.
And Trump lists are just pretending that he
didn't do it.
And some of the left is furious.
So what I want to discuss with you after we
look at the Clippers, did this make sense?
Let's take a look at what Joe Biden had to
say.
Rioting is not protesting.
Looting is not protesting.
Setting fires is not protesting.
None of this is protesting.
It's lawlessness.
Plain and simple.
And those who do it should be prosecuted.
Violence will not bring change and only bring
destruction.
It's wrong in every way.
It divides instead of unites, destroys businesses,
only hurts the working families that serve
the community.
It makes things worse across the board, not
better.
No, it's not what Dr. King or John Lewis taught.
And it must.
And so on the facts.
I agree with Joe Biden here.
Rioting is not protesting.
Looting is not protesting.
And setting fires is not protesting in the
sense that it will bring productive change.
Now, I know that there are people who will
respond and say you don't get to set the terms
of what counts as protesting.
OK, well, we'll get to that in a little bit.
But the possible folly of Joe Biden doing
this is that the right is just pretending
he didn't do it.
They're continuing to say, why won't Joe Biden
denounce violence even though he's done it?
And there's a slice of the left that is absolutely
furious with Joe Biden here.
Now, I'm not saying it's all the left or a
huge portion, but it's certainly a very loud
slice of the left, particularly online.
And the reason that some on the left are mad
at Joe Biden for doing this is they say that
he's playing into the idea that it's his supporters
who are being violent.
Yet the idea being by Joe Biden coming out
and saying, no matter who's doing it, I'm
against the violence.
It sort of frames it up as Joe Biden acknowledging
that it is his supporters being violent and
telling them to stop.
I think that there are two sides to this.
So, first of all, I find it completely reasonable
and unproblematic that Joe Biden says violence
is bad and I'm against it.
It's insane that it has to be said.
But he said it and he said, no matter who
does the violence, I'm against the violence.
But the second piece is that it's important
to clarify at every opportunity that almost
nobody on the left is being violent, that
a lot of the violence is provocateurs and
right wingers.
And I hate to say this, but by and large,
the leftists that are being violent are overwhelmingly
not people supporting Joe Biden.
And often individuals who see Joe Biden as
as much of a problem or almost as much of
a problem as Donald Trump.
So if there is a criticism of Joe Biden here,
it's that he arguably, indirectly or implicitly
seems to be acknowledging or conceding that
some of his supporters are being violent.
And I really don't think that that's the case
at all.
I've not really seen evidence of that.
So I don't believe there's any problem with
Joe Biden denouncing violence in principle.
I do think it's sort of like when, you know,
there is an Islamic terror attack and right
wingers start saying, why didn't this individual
Muslim person who had nothing to do with it
denounced the violence?
Well, most people denounce violence implicitly.
Most people are against violence.
I don't know whether that is even something
that should be expected, particularly when
Joe Biden isn't in power and there's no evidence
that it is his supporters that are doing anything.
But what I would like to see more of is Joe
Biden aggressively placing the blame where
it should be placed.
Biden should be saying or let me go back.
There are people saying by doing this, Joe
Biden is hinting that he's going to police
and limit protests as president and limit
free speech.
That's not at all what Biden is doing here.
And in fact, the Obama Biden administration
had a completely normal relationship with
the press.
Trump is the one that's authoritarian and
dystopian when it comes to a free press.
And ultimately, this is a sort of discussion
of the Martin Luther King perspective on protests
versus the Malcolm X perspective.
And one of the things that most resonates
with me that Dr. King often said was the problem
with going to looting, arson, violence as
a form of protest is not whether it's morally
defensible.
Maybe it is.
That's a perfectly reasonable conversation
to have.
But the small percentage who choose to do
it often end up hurting themselves.
And when protests go to violence, looting,
et cetera, it very often backfires and hurts
the very people that we are trying to help
through our activism.
That was this is Martin Luther King's view.
And you can extensively find interviews with
him on YouTube where he says that.
That's my take on it.
So on the facts, I do tend to agree with Joe
Biden.
I think the framing of Biden must announced.
Biden must denounce.
He does.
And they just keep saying Biden must announce
his if he didn't do it.
That's where it starts to get a little problematic.